um
hi good evening my name is alan gerber
i'm the director
of the institution for social and policy
studies at yale
isps is holding a series of events
this year bringing together experts from
yale and beyond
to shed light on key questions
concerning american politics governance
and democracy tonight's event is
sponsored by
isps democracy which is an isps program
that aims to further research and public
discussion
of representation and democratic policy
making
we have a number of events planned for
this spring please be on the lookout
for them if you would like to learn more
about
these isps events through isps democracy
and also isps research please visit the
isps website
isps isps.yale.edu
and i would like to just begin by not
only thanking the panelists but also
thanking
the organizers of the panel pam green
pamela monica tori bilsky and lamar peer
so here are the logistics for tonight's
event
after i introduce the panelists and we
have a
panel presentation and a panel
discussion there will be a question and
answer period
please send questions uh throughout the
session using the q
a button at the bottom of the zoom
screen
um it's very useful if you can keep your
questions to
a relatively compact you know short
uh sentence or two um that facilitates
both our ability to process the question
and also to
to field it to the panelists um i also
want to
note that tonight's event is being
recorded and
also that if you need technical
assistance just email
isps at yale.edu
so um let me now welcome tonight's
panelists
i'm going to introduce all three of the
panelists uh
at once and then they're gonna speak uh
speak in alphabetical order
um once the introduction is concluded um
first phil goff uh goff is the
carl hovland professor of african
american studies and psychology
phil joined the yale faculty in 2020
he is the co-founder and ceo of the
center for policing equity
which is the world's largest research
and action think tank on race and
policing
and it hosts an unparalleled collection
of police behavioral data
in the national science foundation
funded national
justice database professor goff is a
recognized
national leader in the science of
policing and racial bias
dr goff has won two american
psychological association early career
awards
the association for psychological
science rising star award
and the national organization of black
law enforcement executives
lloyd seely award among many others
he was also a panelist on
president obama's task force on 21st
century policing
has provided congressional testimony
on many occasions and regularly appears
uh
on cable news and other media outlets
we're delighted to have uh bill goff
here this evening
our second speaker will be jacob hacker
jacob is the stanley b resort professor
of political science
and he served as isps director from 2011
to 2020.
he's a member of the american academy of
arts and sciences
the national academy of social insurance
and also was the 2020 robert ball award
winner
for the national academy of social
insurance
he's known for his writings and research
on american politics and public policy
and is a pioneer in the development of
health care policy
especially the public option um
look forward to your remarks jacob um
and then we have fiona scott morton
um scott morton is the theodore
nirenberg professor of economics at the
school of management
has been on the yale faculty since 1999
served as som associate dean from 2007
to
2010 and um from 2011
2012 professor scott morton served as
the deputy assistant attorney general
for economics
at the antitrust division of the u.s
department of justice
where she helped formulate and enforce
the nation's anti-trust laws and
policies
in 2019 scott morton founded
the thurmond arnold project at yale
named in honor of thurman arnold
yeah law professor and head of the
anti-trust division
from 1938 to 1943 and this is a program
that brings together yale faculty and
students
from across the university the law
school the school of management
as well as scholars from other
institutions to collaborate
on research related to competition
competition policy
and antitrust enforcement welcome fiona
i look forward to your remarks as well
so with that um we can get started um
phil
will start off then jacob then fiona
thanks very much alan and thank you
everybody for spending
part of this at least in the the
northeast a very
snowy tuesday um in in february my
understanding is that
according to my students every time i
lecture it snows
so i was not aware that coming to yale
gave me these forms of
superpowers over over nature but thank
you also for that
um we were asked to talk uh about two
things
um in a sort of brief set of
introductory remarks one is something
that we think is going to happen
in our issue area um and one is
something that we think
should happen and i assume it was
implied but we're not as confident is
going to
um so to give you a context of sort of
what i imagine my issue area is
um it's it's the body politic of
of race in the united states but
particularly within public safety
i don't know if any of you guys noticed
over the summer but that was in the news
a lot
part of the reason was obviously the
conflagration that started in
minneapolis
swept across the entire country and then
became a global
enterprise really a global reckoning
with issues of state violence
race and social hierarchy but part of it
is part of a cycle that we go through in
this country
where we we look at i won't say we
reckon with because we don't but we look
at
the massive past due notice of the
unpaid debt
owed to black folks in this country um
i'm not necessarily only talking about
reparations for slavery
but i am also talking about slavery and
its consequences
and in the wake of this summer part of
what we saw was an awakening to
a literally they're calling it
reimagining public safety but it's an
awakening of
the public imagination for what's
possible
in response to violations of of the
social contract
amongst the most vulnerable think about
it like this
um if i choose to
take allen's wallet right then we can
understand that as me choosing to
violate the sacred trust that allows us
to live together
that social contract and i should have
some consequences
but if part of the calculus for me
taking allen's wallet
is alan or other deans having taken
so much from me that there aren't really
other good options
right i understand that this metaphor
gets fantastical when we're talking
about senior faculty at yale but run
with me for a little bit here
um if the deal is that i have been
placed
with a bad set of options and i choose
one that violates the social contract
when in reality the social contract
really just never included me in the
first place
why is punishment our only response
to that why is it that when someone
chooses a bad option
with a set of bad choices in front of
them that they have that
punishment funded by the state in
communities that are disproportionately
inhabited by the descendants of formerly
enslaved people in this country why are
why is that our policy solution
so that's a big part of what this new
administration is having to wrestle with
and in that moment the defund and the
reimagining
another word has more recently appeared
and that word is abolition
and i want to and to couch both of my
answers about what i think will happen
what i think should happen
in the context of abolition the way we
talk about abolition of the prison
industrial complex which is
historically has been mostly prisons and
jails and now inc increasingly includes
sheriffs and police we think about that
as something the removal
of the bad thing the cancer that is that
is poisoning the body politic
but one of the greatest sort of
champions of the idea of particularly
prison abolition
angela davis when she writes in 2005
essentially a retrospective of her
life's work to that point she calls the
book
she calls the book abolition democracy
which is a hearkening back
to the language of du bois in 1935 when
he's talking about black reconstruction
and her first book in 1971 while
incarcerated
right called when they come in the
morning it's a collection of essays from
people who have been
involved in the criminal legal system um
and she chooses julian bond
to write the forward to that and what
does julian bond write about do boys in
1935 saying no one has done anything
since so when du bois talks about
abolition democracy
he's not talking about the the the uh us
system post the
emancipation post slavery he's talking
about an affirmative construction
of political and systemic structures
that rid the body politics of the toxins
of slavery
it's not just the removal of the injury
it's the healing from it that needs to
take generations afterwards
right now that word abolition is
straining what's been possible on the
political left in activist spaces
because it's it's set up as counter to
reform
the idea that you could fix the thing
that is no sometimes you got to burn it
down
and start anew that's the conversation
that happened
happening outside of washington dc in
terms of how we manage
things that we're going to call crime
but really it's violations of the social
contract among
the most vulnerable so as my time starts
to begin to come to an end what do i
what do i think is going to happen
and what do i think should happen what's
going to happen
is that this administration which is
made up of a mix of folks who are
old guard people doing reform trying to
fix the things that we've got
and a mix of folks who are really
excited for something new
there is going to be stuff put on the
table that looks exactly like what it
did
at the end of the previous
administration that being specifically
the justice and policing act right this
is a
bill that passed out of the house didn't
get a vote on the floor of the senate
in part because um there were competing
ideas about it but in part because
frankly there was no incentive for
anybody to introduce it
what it will do is set forth a bunch of
things that will make policing
better reduce qualified immunity which
means that if a police officer did
something that was unreasonable they can
be held accountable to it
it'll lower the 242 standard which means
that instead of
a willful discrimination you can get
reckless
it will allow the federal government to
engage in things around accountability
and public safety they haven't done
before
but what it won't do is set up the
structures that prevent someone from
having to call 9-1-1 in the first place
and it also won't allow for the
resources
that are the appropriate response for
instance a mental health crisis or a
substance abuse crisis
or a crisis of suicide it won't send
those resources in response and it won't
send them affirmatively
so the kind of legislation that can get
through congress and the kind of
executive orders that will come out of
uh the president's come off of the
president's desk the first time through
that's going to be the reform the things
that are bold action in the context of
what happened
before this summer but what
should happen and i'm less angry about
is a fuller reckoning of what our
systems of justice at the federal
level have failed to render particularly
to black brown
and native folks in this country
and i mean quite literally a reckoning
an accounting
what has doj done that has
harmed native folks um chicano folks
black folks where can we get that
codified because that's
that reckoning is the first step towards
actually fixing i'm not calling for
massive amounts of funding for all of
that yet i'm calling for the
infrastructure
that makes it morally irresistible to
take that next step
because as we're moving towards progress
along public safety where i'm very
concerned
there will be a critical incident there
will be
a murder there will be an assault there
will be something
ghastly there will be those who seek to
weaponize that
incident as a cause to reinvest
in the kind of policing we've had up
until now um
to to humiliate or to embarrass
or to shame the folks who have been
calling for
more radical change and if the
infrastructure
isn't set up so that we can continue to
move forward when
some of these experiments that we're
trying out in many of the cities across
the country
fail then we're going to do the exact
same thing we've done every other time
that we've tried to reimagine public
safety
which is forget about the people who
most need that safety
and re-entrench ourselves in old
orthodoxies
so my hope for this administration is
that there is enough
new energy both inside and outside that
the pressure stays on
that we build for the long term and not
just in reaction
on to the the passions of this summer
but what i know is going to happen
is that incremental change is going to
move forward
and it's going to be up to us to decide
whether or not that's
enough
well first of all thank you so much
everyone for being here thank you
alan lamore pam for putting this
together thanks
fiona and phil for for being part of
this panel
and thank phil in particular for those
really stirring remarks
my conclusions my issue area is
completely different but my conclusions
are somewhat similar
and maybe this is going to be a theme
for the evening
because the gap between what should be
done and what will be possible in
the immediate term is pretty great not
withstanding the fact that those who
want
to act boldly in these areas are in a
stronger position than we would have
expected
a year or two ago um so let me
let me say a bit about the issue area
it's not going to be a surprise to you
that i'm going to talk a bit about
health care
alan already said that but i wanna
that's a huge area
and i'm not an expert on public health
so i'm not gonna say
a huge amount uh or very much at all
about
the response to covet 19. um i'm going
to focus mostly on the unfinished
business of
of american health care reform namely
the
the the fact the united states is the
only
rich democracy that lacks the kind of
two
part solution that every other country
in that set
has come up with a system that covers
everyone and has some
mechanism for for controlling costs
system-wide
in particular for restraining health
care prices which
which in the absence of such systems
tend to grow
uh much more quickly than the cost of
living than people's
standard than people's incomes and then
what governments can afford
um fiona knows a lot about that side of
the story
and i'll be interested to see if her
thoughts on antitrust extended at all
into the healthcare realm
um but but the areas i'm going to focus
on really are around
the broadening of health insurance and
and whether or not that broadening can
go hand in hand
with serious efforts to rein in
america's exorbitant health care costs
now as i said my conclusions are
are somewhat similar to phil's right the
we need to build for the long term
because we're not uh we're not going to
see the kind of
transformative change we need in the
near term
but that's not to say that the changes
in near term could not
both make an enormous difference and
contribute
to that long-term transformation now
what what is this should what is what
are the transformative changes we need
now
i mean i i think notwithstanding the
fact that we
um that we have um
we're very far away from having
universal insurance
and effective cost control today
i actually think a lot of the core
elements of what needs to be done
have actually been articulated and not
just by movement leaders but by people
in public office
and i won't try to make the argument for
why
a medicare for all may be a bridge too
far in the
in the medium term but instead just say
that
whatever your views on whether we can
move to univer
a universal public insurance system
there is broad agreement that we need to
massively
expand public coverage and the cost
controls
and and rationalization that goes with
it
that we need to make sure that um every
uh every citizen and eventually every
resident in the united states
has protection against ruinous
healthcare costs and access to medical
care
and um and notably that um
that we need to do this with with an
understanding of what we've learned over
the last generation namely that
that the cost of health care require is
growing
so quickly and is and the um
and the private insurance models are
shifting so much more
cost onto patients and restricting
networks such that
unless we put in place a system that
allows people to have
broad access to providers
a relatively affordable out-of-pocket
costs for care and coverage and and
and coverage that's there um when they
need it
we're not going to achieve that so it's
going to require public action
before the election um the uh
biden campaign actually articulated in
concert with the um with the
sanders camp a set of principles that
are now known as the
unity task force document and and the
the important aspect of that was that
a core thing that they said was that
they wanted to have a public insurance
option
such as the one that i've articulated
that i've advocated for for many years
and that would be built on the medicare
infrastructure and would use medicare
provider
providers and medicare payment rates but
improve those over time
and that it would be used to expand
coverage for people who live in states
that that where medicaid was not
expanded in response to affordable care
act
and i think if if it were possible
that would be the right template to to
pursue the
the challenge of course is that we are
despite the fact that those who are
advocating these reforms are in a
majority position
uh in the sense that the senate the
house and the white house
are in the hands of the party that would
like to do these things
um that party has a very narrow majority
and so
we've all been debating and discussing
the filibuster in its future
and to a very great extent the extent of
up changes that are possible are going
to depend
on whether or not the filibuster is
retained in the senate
um that debate um will not play out
in the context of health care it will
likely play out in the context of voting
reform
um and and i don't know how it will how
it will be resolved though
i'm i must say that um that there is
more prospect for
for the elimination of the filibuster
for ordinary legislation there has been
it
at any point in the last 20 25 years
but that that prospect still seems um
fairly elusive
given the current configuration of power
so given that i've written recently that
i think it's very important that
those who act who are in support of the
more ambitious reforms i've articulated
or even more ambitious reforms like
moving to
a universal medicare system really need
to think about how to use
the opportunities that we have in the
medium term
to lay the groundwork for longer term
change so this is really similar to the
challenge that phil was talking about
i do think it's about movement building
but it's also about using
doing what i've called using power to
build using policy to build
power so how do you put in place
policies that will build constituencies
and trust
and and positive results that will make
it more likely that you can move towards
more ambitious reforms in the future
i've written a whole article on this in
the journal of health politics policy
and law that
um that just came out but the three
elements that i've emphasized
are that they that the um
those who are seeking these more
ambitious reforms need to
upgrade the affordable care act and in
particular to make it more its subsidies
more generous
um for coverage and um and to fix a lot
of the defects in the log that have been
introduced
uh uh and or were not fixed uh in the
last
um in the last administration and
there's already a lot of executive
action that's moved in that direction
but it's going to take a legislation
the second thing that i've argued is
that you need to build the
infrastructure for bigger reforms and
that would mean improving and expanding
uh key aspects of medicare in particular
making medicare a better program for
older americans in a more efficient
program
and then finally i think it's extremely
important
to try to build movements and that's
been involved policy so if you think
about the covid response
the idea of building a public health
jobs corps that could help enroll people
in coverage
could be a really important part of also
building uh building political power and
grassroots
enthusiasm for broader reforms in the
future
the last thing i'll say is that there
really is in the absence of the
filibuster only one fast track in
american politics today it's called the
budget reconciliation process
and um the budget reconciliation process
will be the vehicle for the the
uh current legislation the pandemic
relief legislation before congress
you only get one and at most in this
year two bytes of the
of the reconciliation apple and that
means that the
challenge is going to be whether the
next big reconciliation bill will
include core health care provisions
remember there's also a huge push for
infrastructure
and and a broad response to climate
change
and i think that there's a real question
of whether or not you can do
these kinds of reforms simultaneously
and next year
we're already going to be into an
election year that's going to be deeply
freighted in 2022
and so to me in the absence of
filibuster reform
the agenda for health care reform is
likely
going to be more limited than many
advocates would want simply because of
the crowded
reform agenda that's going to occur with
only one
big fast train leaving the station but
with that i'm going to return to my
earlier remarks and say
that one should not despair but but
think about the ways in which
these opportunities in the near term can
be used to build power
and better policy for the long term
great i guess i'm up next uh it was
wonderful to listen to both of you
um i will actually echo jacob and say
that i have that
same theme in the following sense my
area of expertise is as
alan said competition policy and
anti-trust
and people don't usually think of
antitrust as
social justice but it is for the
following reason
most shareholders most uh people
entitled to corporate profit monopoly
profit
are the top one percent and the top one
percent
are mostly white and when you take a
dollar of corporate profit and you turn
it into competition
instead that those monopoly profits
don't get earned and they get turned
into low prices or better quality
and those benefit all consumers and all
consumers are obviously much more
diverse than the top
one or five percent so when we enforce
the
competition then when we make our
markets more competitive we are
in fact redistributing income reducing
income inequality and helping uh the
more vulnerable disproportionately
um so the last 40 years of evidence
has now been made much more clear i
would say over the last five or ten
years
to tell us that we have a competition
problem in the united states we do not
have enough competitive markets we have
too many monopolies
and settings with market power uh what
should we do about that
uh one one thing we could do is to
strengthen the anti-trust laws uh this
is already happening
uh senator amy klobuchar has already
introduced a bill to strengthen the
antitrust laws this is
excellent uh there'll be more ideas i
think in this area maybe more
bills that would be great uh there's
biport bipartisan support for reforming
the antitrust laws in the house
i expect that we will get a movement
here
and the reason is because additional
antitrust enforcement and
stronger anti-trust laws would generate
more competition which as i said is good
for consumers especially the bottom end
that appeals to democrats
republicans in general don't care about
consumers they care about corporate
profit and so republicans in general
have not been in favor of stronger
anti-trust laws but rather weaker
trust laws and that's in fact why why we
are where we are
but republicans do value small business
okay and when you look at corporate
profits in america what you see is a
widening
uh let's like income inequality only for
corporations
the money is all going to the biggest
four or five uh
platforms really if you think about the
ones that everybody talks about google
facebook apple amazon that's where all
the money is
so the small business coalition runs
from you know
a t and comcast and john deere all the
way down to the corner coffee shop
all of those parties would like to
preserve their own profits and not give
them to google
and so they are willing to ally with the
consumers to have stronger anti-trust
laws
and those uh corporations have senators
and representatives
so it is possible i think uh that we
will get
antitrust reform um soon and what would
that entry trust reform look like
um it would change the burden of proof
in more settings that is to say
if two corporations want to merge rather
than the government needing to prove
that that's harmful
we would make the corporations prove
that it's fine
okay and what that does is it just
lowers the cost
uh to enforce the law because the
government can uh doesn't have to spend
as much money or time or resources to
figure out what's best to do
it increases the budgets of the agencies
the draft laws would repudiate
explicitly repudiate cases that courts
got wrong in the past where that allowed
market power to build that protected
monopolies
and a big area of interest uh for
economists and lawyers both in this
in this space is uh protecting
competition
when nascent or potential uh competitors
are excluded or bought so think about
facebook and
instagram or any setting where the rival
isn't yet really
fully in the market but is coming and
the action of the dominant firm is to
buy them or to exclude them we want to
try to protect competition in those
cases where oftentimes the benefit to
consumers is innovation
it's not so much price but it's about a
new competitor entering and doing
something in a different way
so that's what i expect to happen what
should happen
uh is an additional step beyond
antitrust so if you think about what
happened between october
and december of 2020 there were
five or six enormous anti-trust cases
that were filed by government
plaintiffs we had the house report on
digital platforms early in the fall as i
mentioned
then the department of justice and some
states sued google over at search
monopoly
texas and some other states sued google
over ad tech the ftc and some states
sued facebook uh for its monopoly
position
so that was all very exciting we caught
up to europe after 10 years of delay
and everybody said wow we've done it now
the problem is that once we come out of
covid and insurrection then we start to
pay attention to this again
we're going to notice that the first
hearing in these cases is
september 2023 okay that we're going to
have the case then we're going to have
to wait for the judge to write an
opinion then there will be an appeal
and we have to wait for that to be
scheduled and we have to brief it and
then we have a remedy stage at the end
and
all in all this is going to take a long
time
and i think citizens and the
aforementioned small businesses are not
going to want to wait that long
and they're going to want to regulate
europe
uh in december 15th released draft
regulations to
control digital platforms once again uh
lapping the united states
but we can watch those and react to them
and i think it's not going to take us 10
years
to pass some digital platform regulation
again the same coalition the consumers
and small businesses
and the things that we ought to put in
that regulation
are much much more consumer protection
which we really don't have online so
what kinds of buttons can be pre-ticked
when you go on a site buttons that make
you buy things and subscribe to things
and share your data which you didn't
plan to do but the buttons are
pre-ticked
what about auto renewals what about
terms and conditions that are 50 pages
long
and just legally written and nobody
understands them and it could say give
away your first born in there and you
would still click
i agree what about uses for my data that
i don't fully understand and that
are vague and maybe actually aren't even
adhered to by the platform that's
claiming they do that
there's other issues like
interoperability between businesses so
for example
when i send email from the yale isp to
the you know to somebody on gmail or
hotmail
or at harvard it arrives uh and that
is because email's interoperable well
there are lots of
uh digital platforms that are not
interoperable and that is a problem
because uh then i'm stuck inside that
platform and i can't communicate outside
it and that gives the platform a lot of
market power
so interoperability would tremendously
increase
competition and then the third thing
that should go and there's lots of
things you could put in this regulation
but i'm just going to highlight three of
them for you a third one i think
is really important is thinking about
the split of the surplus between the
platform
and the everybody else the small
businesses and the users
and that goes to some extent to the
bargaining power of those
users and small businesses because they
don't have anywhere else to go because
it's a monopoly so that's one
way that this arises but the other way
is
maybe we should give businesses and
people property rights over their data
so that they can extract something from
the platform
for sharing it or the platform doesn't
get to use it for free
but has to actually talk to them about
whether
they uh what they would like to be paid
for that data
or for example um should businesses be
allowed to use the
up features of the operating system or
the platform that the platforms
own applications use so platforms have
access to certain apis or functionality
should the competing applications on the
platform also have access to that
those apis or functionality that would
be something else regulation
could do so those kinds of things go
into regulation it's a sort of a
pro-competitive pro-consumer type of
thing i have in mind
and i think again there's a broad
coalition that would like this
um you need legislation to pass that and
you also
probably need a new agency a regulator
that is
designed to look after digital platforms
and that has a consumer protection
element
a competition element and some special
expertise in in digital businesses which
by the way
will be nearly everything um when when
you think about
the fact that stop and shop is
delivering me groceries uh
by an elect letting me order over the
internet so
this is a very big remit and it needs to
be done well but i think it is important
to move forward on
okay thank you all very much that was
really interesting and
great perspectives on three really
important areas
of of public policy um
do any of the panelists have any
questions or comments
inspired by your colleagues
presentations
um i i i
well i have a question that echoes one
that was asked by the
uh in the q a that i can see here from
the the attendees which is to fiona
which is
just what you think if anything is going
to take place in the healthcare
anti-trust arena
um i think that there'll be vigorous
enforcement
relative to the last four years and that
might show up
um if you give the ftc more money that
will show up in pharma
that will show up in hospitals and
hospital mergers
um that might actually
appear also a little bit in regulations
that
have up till now actually protected
incumbents from competition instead of
exposing incumbents to competition
um so i i don't think it's
gonna do what you your remarks talked
about jacob which is
really giving you know more access to
more people
but every little bit counts and the more
market power every doctor group or
hospital group or drug
has means that especially as we see
insurers and employers shifting more of
the costs
directly onto enrollees they're going
out and paying these out of pocket
prices that keep climbing
um so i think it is an important way to
help
regular citizens uh by lowering those
costs
thanks
good um any other any other comments
from panelists
uh regarding the presentations
i i just think i'm i'm not the political
scientist i'm just the economist but i
i i do have to say that it seems to me
that voting
and voting rights is the way that you
build power
i mean if you're going to do what phil
wants to do and what jacob wants to do
you have to elect
representatives that also want to do
that
and if most people in the country want
these things which i think is true
then we need to make our elected
representatives
reflect those preferences which means
that really the only thing that matters
in the next two years
is voting rights
yeah i mean i would just say that the
the legislation that probably most of
the attendees are aware of that would
address these issues is hr1 or
s1 in the in the senate and of course
the numbers
is symbolic of this priority that's
placed on it by the congressional
leadership
if not the biden administration um
and i would just i won't go into the
specifics of this bill i did a big
podcast um
for deconstructed which is a you know
kind of progressive podcast if you're
interested but
but i will say that proposed my earlier
comments about the filibuster
that by far the most likely scenario
under which the filibuster falls
is that um particularly the voting
rights portion of that which is
um now bears the imprimatur of
of the great late john lewis um that
that
becomes the subject of a filibuster that
is
broken by democrats to pass
voting reform the question mark there
and of course it would also not just
bear the imprimatur of john lewis
but carry with it the passion of um
of the movements that phil was talking
about but the question mark there is
not just whether that would happen um
and it would require a really serious
push by the bind administration which so
far has been a little bit
um wary of declaring itself
fully committed to pushing this as a as
its core priority
uh despite the fact that it's high in
the congressional agenda but it would
also
um it would also um
it would also it also raises a question
of whether some kind of specific carve
out would be
engineered to the filibuster for voting
rights legislation that wouldn't apply
to things like
the public option which by the way could
be done through reconciliation as i said
but um but even then may not be able to
get the votes of
the the the holy trinity of uh moderate
uh democrats um seminar tester
and and mansion um so um
what was i gonna say oh so so one one
last little point on filibuster reform
which is i think kind of of interest um
to those
in the in the audience it because it is
so fundamental to all of the issues
we've talked about here
is that um is that there is also
a push for kind of um alternatives to
the filibuster that wouldn't
go all the way to uh pure majority rule
so
if people are interested we can talk
about those but um
they might involve like restoring the
talking filibuster where
uh where mem where senators would
actually have to stay on the floor
rather than be able to move on to other
business i'm honestly brothers
can i just say especially for those 86
year old senators
i think no bathroom breaks okay
but anyway i'll stop there great thanks
a lot jacob
um phil uh do you have anything you'd
like to say in response to
yeah i was actually about to jump in
without you
you could use it as an opportunity maybe
to elaborate
um when you were saying that you know
you hope that the pressure stays on
um you know tell me if you could just
elaborate um
uh um you know what what is uh can you
unpack that a little bit
uh as well yeah so i i find it's it's
interesting
um fiona the framing that sort of voting
rights above all
else because without people who are
sympathetic to this we don't get any
other things done
um there is there's a part of me in both
in my brain and in my life that
um that is committed to that
understanding of it
and yet also i don't think anyone who
was elected
um to federal office prior to may 25th
um would have been discussing police
abolition without the movements that are
outside
of this so sometimes it's the case that
what you want is you want to get um
the better of two or three or four
options
um into the elected seat but sometimes
you just need to change the conditions
on the ground
to make it unreasonable that there
wouldn't be a movement going forward
you had republicans in the senate
judiciary hearing
on issues of policing calling folks like
me
to come talk to them about racism in
policing
an area that's that's that's not their
issue but you couldn't see what was
happening across the united states
and the and the the public protests in
thailand
right um call it call with signs and say
black lives matter and say
we should do nothing so my hope is that
the kind of engagement and activism that
was spawned both of
being locked inside for those couple of
first couple of months
and of seeing the a world that doesn't
look like our values playing out on the
streets
of what does look like our communities
i'm hoping that engagement stays
up right so it's the case that because i
get to teach undergraduates
and i occasionally talk with high school
students i deal with not only people who
have a lot more hair than me
people with a lot more energy and a lot
more devotion to these issues
i have not seen in my adult life
the level not just a political
engagement but a political
sophistication in education
and the desire to take a long-form view
so what i mean allen to keeping the
pressure on
you know when obama was leaving office
he said you guys could have pushed me to
do more
right and there's the the the famous bit
both you know fdr there's a version of
fdr doing and of lbj doing it i'm like i
agree with you now go make me do it
right it's fdr first right but the idea
is that
um it's possible to move
the center of political will outside of
the electoral process
and i think it's really important to
name that because in the communities
where i work
there are lots of folks who feel like
the game is already rigged
there's nobody who's going to be passing
any legislation that speaks to their
issues that make their lives easier that
make it more likely that their
proximity of the american dream gets any
closer but i do know how to tick to the
streets i do know how to write a sign
and the more we have folks who are able
to speak to them the less that's
necessary
the more they engage in those kinds of
extra partisan
um uh behaviors right the more we're
gonna get people who are
gonna be closer to them um so my hope
is that we get significantly more of
that and at the same time that we're
expanding voting rights we have folks
who understand that elections are not
the only kind of politics in the country
good separate from that if can i pivot
and ask a question back to the panel as
we move through
yeah yeah i'm i'm so every time i listen
to my brilliant colleagues in other
areas
i'm so eager to just go and take classes
and also to be the
the selfish person in the class who says
how does that relate to my thing
because i'm thinking increasingly about
the social determinants
of safety the way we talk about the
social determinants of health there
isn't a science of this we're trying to
build it up because we've just not
invested
but i'm interested both from jacob and
fiona if you guys can talk about
the ways that you see synergies across
the federal government
in what you're doing because when i talk
about a reckoning i talked about doj
looking back
but it's also hud that needs to look
back right
and it's absolutely like when we're
talking about privacy and surveillance
we're gonna have to talk about antitrust
so in all of the areas where you guys
have expertise
they're not even two degrees removed
from the spaces that if we do things
before policing
to take care of public safety we're
going to need to talk but part of our
our blockages the obstacles is that
these
these issue areas become silos within
government and there's not been
conversation
so in this summer of something different
for everyone
i'm wondering the degree to which you've
been able to talk to folks in other
areas about what you feel like needs to
move forward
and the ways in which we can start to
break down some of those silos to get
more accomplished
i have one answer um
at the thurman arnold project we had a
conference uh halfway through january
which you can go look up on the web
uh entitled antitrust and big
ag big agriculture and one of the things
that
is just astonishing i knew relatively
little about agriculture before we
started down this
uh path the conference was run uh
organized primarily by my deputy austin
frerich and
when you go and look at the problems in
rural america
not only do we have incredible market
power by
slaughterhouses and meatpackers and the
guys who buy the beef and the lamb and
sell the tractors
and the grain monsanto and john deere
and so on
who are they employing they're employing
black and brown workers
immigrants they're not paying them the
working conditions are terrible
why is that because they have monopsony
power they're the only employer in the
town not only are the only seller of
meat so the meat price is high
the wages are low the environmental
degradation is really high
the rural community is then hollowed out
because the jobs are poor and the air
quality is awful
the animals are unhappy and badly cared
for so it's a
confluence of places where you don't
want to look at it just as the
department of agriculture or the
department of justice or the epa
you want to say all of these things are
going wrong in these rural communities
at the same time
and if we went in and we looked at how
concentrated they are and we tried to
make there be more choice for employers
if we if there were
an environmental regulation that limited
the size of hog farms
that would reduce air pollution it would
create more employers
for the workers it would improve the
lives of the animals i mean just
everything it's like one bird and sorry
one stone and eight birds
um and that's a place where i think the
silos need to break down and i want to
jump
i want to get to the questions but let
me just say the obvious phil which is
that
we're not talking about health care the
same way we were before the pandemic or
before the protests of the summer
the degree to which we people who are on
the
front lines thinking through health care
are having to confront the
profound racial inequities um and class
and equities that are embedded in the
system and that would not be fixed
were by conventional reforms if we were
not
if we don't confront those inequities
frontally that that is just a sea change
and thinking that i think
in the long term we'll deliver a lot of
good unfortunately in the near term
um this has just been a heartbreaking
reminder this period has been a
heartbreaking reminder of how
unfinished that the agenda of um
of systemic reform and it really is so
that that would be my my quick answer
okay good all right thank you um those
are those
really extremely interesting remarks let
me turn now to some of the questions
um that uh that our audience has been
has asked and is continuing to ask i'm
just going to
sort of re re read a few of them and
then get some answers
uh from the panelists um phil
i i there was a question for you that i
am having trouble finding
but it was a very specific question
about um
so suppose you were to uh reduce the
money spent on the
a police force and redirect it into some
community spending
um with an effort to improve the um
improve the the quality of life uh in
the affected communities
um how would what would be the best way
in your view
to to spend that money uh for that
purpose and i i don't know if you have
any thoughts about that i know you've
been
very involved in some of these efforts
yeah you can't find it because i i typed
an answer
um so it showed up in the answer section
no but it's okay i'm i'm very happy to
speak a portion of it as well
um it's a great question i have been
thinking a great deal about how we how
we do redesign
um uh instead of just reimagining
because at some point you've got to
actually do some things because there's
bodies falling
um and i think it also goes to there's
another question to chat about
um the trade-off between short-term
short-term reforms
getting what you can and the longer term
of of getting to where we need to go
i'll say that i have been in a bunch of
spaces
where mayors and governors and state
reps are saying we don't
know how to get from here to a smaller
um police force size we don't know how
to get from here
to to better so we need a bunch of
research before we move
now i'm a scientist right i'm i'm in
favor of more research
nobody who wants more data on public
safety than i do i i swear i would i
would
challenge any of you to a fight on it
but that's not to say we need to do the
science first
sometimes the science has to come
afterwards and there are
literally thousands of natural
experiments happening all over the
country right now
i don't know what the right percentage
of budget is to take away from law
enforcement
and put into mental health versus
substance abuse versus child welfare
versus green spaces
versus food insecurity i know that each
of those things are really good
predictors
of safety and of police intervention
later on
um so the more money you've got in um uh
social services
particularly for mental health and
substance abuse the less likely you are
to be calling 9-1-1
and in cities like san francisco and
oakland
um and austin where they have at houston
now where they've taken
law enforcement and segregated out the
mental health response so it's just
social workers
you're seeing a two and three and in
austin a 4x
response um to 9-1-1 9-1-1 calls go up
four times on certain weekends just
because they know they can get a mental
health
response that suggests a huge under
utilization of mental health resources
which is an unintended insight of this
moment where we're having this reckoning
with policing
but the long short is we don't know
exactly how much
so what we should be doing is a
long-term investment
in science so that all of these natural
experiments
are yielding information some insights
into how we think about scaling
and to the person who asked about
short-term versus long-term
i know that jacob and fiona have things
to say about it and i want to be out of
the way so they can answer
um but in the context of policing it is
often the case
well we can't get to that so let's do
this small thing has been the way that
movements
and requests for progress die
the real answer to this i think is we
have to have a shared idea about where
we're going
that way if i'm saying we want to
abolish
the death penalty that's not in the way
of shrinking the size of law enforcement
and if we're saying we want to give
feedback back on racial equity and
police behavior
that's not in the way there are even
some trainings that are not in the way
provided they don't create
a whole economic system that feeds the
beast of unions and
and and out of control growth in law
enforcement but without that shared
understanding of where we're going
without the road
map right my what we can get now is in
the way of someone else's revolution
and too often when we're trying to
combine movements with science
smart policy to try and save people's
lives with a broader sense of what
democracy can be
that's where we end up cannibalizing
each other and getting absolutely
nothing
which by the way is what it feels like
we got each and every single time we've
had a reckoning on policing
prior to that what we got for michael
brown jr what we got for
um rodney king what we got in 1968 what
we got out after tulsa
good thank you phil um let me ask jacob
a question um jacob what would you say
um so i i can certainly
imagine and i i heard your your
arguments for
why it's a a moral imperative to
expand the health care coverage and i i
find those those
very compelling personally what would
you say is the best
argument against the the public option
so
as this debate unfolds what do you
anticipate
i mean not not what will be you know i
mean i
i guess i could ask you what arguments
you think will be made
against it when it comes up but but what
do you think of as some
what are the what are arguments against
it that you that you you know caused you
to pause at all
are any any of them reasonable in your
view or
um yeah yeah i know i mean look if if
i wouldn't be a good academic if i
wasn't racked with self-doubt
uh right so um no i mean i recognize
that the public option is not the be
i'll end all of health of health care
reform um
but i i think that um and let me just
say about
what i consider to be the kind of
important developments and thinking
about the public option that have taken
place
since the the idea first emerged on the
public agenda during the debate over the
affordable care act in 2009
10. so so during that discussion
i think the public option was seen as as
mostly a kind of tac
tacked on addition to a a reform
framework that mostly followed the model
that
had been passed in massachusetts right
where
people would have access to private
insurance and
that would be regulated and the
trade-off was essentially or the bargain
was essentially that
the insurance companies would would
essentially agree to be regulated and
not
be able to discriminate against
unhealthy patients or charge them higher
rates
in return they would basically get a
bundle of money from government
and um to to provide that coverage
and the um the forces of kind of
competition
choosing among these plans uh would
basically bring down
cost for that coverage over time it was
seen as ancillary to a fundamentally
employment-based system and i
you know so that was never my vision but
that was really where it was
in 2009-10 and if you look at where it's
gone and i think if you put a public
option into that system
it's basically there's it's basically
it's very likely to get marginalized
right
um and so where the debate is where i
think the debate is gone and needs to
continue to go
is the idea that the public insurance
option should be something quite
distinct from private insurance plans
um it should be modeled after medicare
um it should be
public in the sense that it's it's
pulling the risks
with the federal government essentially
managing it and paying the cost
it should have a broad access to
providers and it should use
regulated payment rates and
and that it should be something that is
available not just to those who don't
have coverage to their employer but to
those who have coverage from their
employer that doesn't
uh doesn't provide adequate uh
protection
and so in that world i think the public
option has a lot more transformative
potential i mean
on one side you'll have critics
conservatives saying
it's going to be uh you know a slippery
slope to
universal medicare um on the and
and many advocates might think that as
well and on the other side you're going
to have
medicare for all advocates saying you
know if you have that system
it's not going to be robust enough to be
able to provide the
the the kind of protection the citizens
need that you could get through a
universal system and it you know the
insurance companies have figured out how
to gain
medicare they'll figure out how to gain
it and um
and to me the you know so that's i think
the vision has really evolved quite a
bit
into something where if you
where the public option would be seen as
something universally available
nationwide to everyone regardless of
whether they had coverage through
another source
and that it would uh and that would be
built on a public platform
but i i do think there are real risks
even then because
the and fiona knows this well the
fundamental reality is that if we don't
figure out how to provide coverage
affordably
right any platform we build isn't going
to be sustainable
and um and that's that's the path we're
on today it's the path we've been on
and i still think there's not enough
guarantee in current models
to be able to really provide that kind
of coverage uh on generous terms
over time and so to me that's where a
lot of the
the most significant thinking is gonna
need to take place
um and um you know one thing the
pandemic i think has really driven home
is that
um is it like a lot of the things we
took for granted about what works in
health care
um you know are pretty fragile and um
and the kind of the models of payment
and delivery of care
that we have uh that have developed the
united states
can produce deeply while they can
produce really wonderful outcomes for
these deeply perverse ones as well and
so
to me that's going to be the sort of
next frontier of thinking about the
public option
great thanks very much that's very very
interesting jacob
um a question uh that i'd like to send
to fiona
um a question on uh the
the questioner asks you to comment
on the facebook oversight board as a
protector for
consumers rather than an obstacle for
competitors
and let me let me just um uh pivot on
that a little bit and just say
um what do you think about the general
idea of self-regulation
um uh by these uh these large tech by
these tech giants as a
as a regulatory strategy to you um
because that seems to be at least
you know i think that's the that's it
that's sort of the impulse i think of
that
uh that facebook supreme court i guess
is
that they've set up well
many decades perhaps centuries companies
have been in favor of self-regulation
and uh we know why because it doesn't
work
i mean if you have a profit incentive to
engage in a certain behavior that harms
consumers
uh saying you promise not to do it is
not going to be a very foolproof way of
getting that outcome so
i i think in all seriousness this is a
terrible idea and it never works and if
societies want certain outcomes then
they should codify them in the law and
make a regulator and be serious about
holding companies to the standards of
behavior that they want
i think when people ask me about
difficult
first amendment questions and speech and
censorship and whatever about
about the digital platforms my
usual answer is to say that's not my
area of expertise go see
uh go see professor jack balkan at the
law school but also
boy wouldn't it be nice if i could
change my social network
when i didn't like what it was doing i
have a newspaper if i don't if i decided
i didn't like the content of my
newspaper i would subscribe to a
different newspaper
the problem that we have with a lot of
these digital platforms is there isn't
another choice
so i feel like if we could get the
antitrust and the competition policy and
the regulation and the entry barriers
to work better so there was more entry
and more competition and therefore more
choices
that the fraught question of how to
regulate the content of the platform
would become lessened because people
would simply
vote with their feet and go somewhere
else and
that there would still be issues but but
many many people wouldn't
feel as frustrated because they would be
able to move to a place that was giving
them what they wanted
um uh fiona there another question i
just wanted to throw to you
um about uh regulating the uh the tech
companies
i'm gonna i'll read the question um
information technologies do not map to
classical
anti-trust conception of bundled
products information in its collection
permits
the creation of services that are simply
not available to small startups
in particular the social graph like the
human genome is a feature of a natural
the natural world
it has been permitted to be
proprietarily owned
um how should uh how would should
antitrust law address this powerful
inherent feature of an information
economy
i'll also add to this um that some of
these companies might be
um because of network issues natural
monopolies
rather than uh the kinds of uh of
industries that
are you know you have like a classical
competition of a bunch of small firms
how does that affect your perspective
toward regulation
in these markets yeah there are ways to
deal with this problem
the first is to change
laws and regulations to affect the
property rights of the data
right now it's really not clear what
belongs to me in terms of my data what i
can control
how i can control it the same with a
business
if that business finds me through a
platform does that business have a right
to know something about me or can the
platform keep it all and withhold it
from the business
to how much do i share and
is does the business have a right to
sell that on to others
or to use it internally in other
totally unrelated activities that happen
to be under the same corporate umbrella
so there's a whole set of what i might
call consumer protection kinds of issues
around data
that would be very helpful if we had
more laws and regulations around
the second issue the network effects
issue comes back to interoperability
which i mentioned earlier
the internet is a giant network
of email traffic where all of us have an
isp
that had that where that's our home and
we can write to each other
and we can write to anybody who has and
i who's on an isp that conforms to the
internet protocol
that is not true if we think about
facebook that is not true if we think
about
proprietary social networks there's no
reason why we as a society
can't decide that social networks should
be interoperable just the same way email
and telephones are i have an att phone
it can call your verizon phone
why is that because it's a rule
and we could have those same rules for
other businesses also and once you have
that rule
then it doesn't matter how big your
social network is
because the users of it can communicate
with everybody else on other social
networks just like i can have a very
tiny isp
and it's on the internet communicating
with you know emailing everybody else
so this is a very simple idea we've used
it before
and it gets rid of entry barriers uh
that are driven by network effects
that's i i've actually never heard that
idea before that's actually a really
neat idea thank you um thank you
fiona um jacob so moving back around the
panel in reverse order
jacob um you mentioned cost control
measures a question it
was asked um what's your favorite um
cost control measure for medical
condition
well i like them all to be honest
i mean i really don't think you know i
really don't don't to use the
cliche right i'm a belt and suspenders
kind of guy when it comes to cost
control we're gonna have to do a lot of
different things
um let me let me mention three
one which is very conventional one
that's kind of a little more out there
and i think
uh links up with what some of what fiona
said and
and a third that um i'll like i'll keep
you guessing and i'll do this quickly
so the first is like um when prices are
too high
you uh it's not a bad idea in the
context of
distorted markets like healthcare to try
to control prices
so that i mean that has been a really
key part of how other countries have
dealt with medical costs
and it should be a key part of how we do
do it
and and it doesn't have to be that
you're dictating the price you could
start by just simply
having a level above which prices cannot
go i mean one of the nice features of
the legislation that fiona helped with
on surprise medical bills was simply
just saying
you know we're not going to say that it
has to be the price x but it cannot be
higher than y
um and because people don't have any
ability to decide in advance that
they're going to get these surprise
medical bills and therefore to choose
what the prices will be
so i've often thought that in addition
to a public option
we should have a basically a a price
ceiling outside of the of the public
option that is based on the public
option prices
but is a multiple of them and is moving
downwards um
that's so price i'm not i'm not saying
that we should have fee for service
medicine forever
um but we have a lot of fee for service
medicine
we should put uh caps on prices it's
what every other country does
um so the second thing is it it actually
relates to the
um to something that fiona was alluding
to which is the amount of the enormous
amount of public investment that goes
into and um public support that goes
into a lot of the
um into a lot of the basic medical goods
that we enjoy
right so pharmaceuticals are a key
example um
so in addition to like thinking about
antitrust i i think the flip side of
that is thinking about
patents and about intellectual property
in a different way
and the the the vaccine development
process i think that we just went
through really
highlights the issue here right if it
absolutely makes sense we should be
pouring billions and billions and
billions
hundreds of billions of dollars into
developing a vaccine for covid19
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
that then the pricing should be entirely
determined by private companies who in
this context may behave in a very
responsible way but in general
the system is really screwed up um so
that
is a big deal and it's going to be a
bigger deal going forward with bio
biotechnological
innovation so i put that there so the
really um
the last kind of idea out there that i
think is
really kind of uh gothian given what
we've said
is that i used to scoff a little bit at
this idea that oh
we should be really thinking a lot about
all the other things that affect health
care
you just can't you just can't see what's
happening before us right now or the
changes in health that are occurring
among key populations without
recognizing
that we're spending in really bad ways
often we're paying it for a really
expensive acute care especially at end
of life
and we should be investing a lot more
and just like when we're thinking about
policing
well should we be trying to deal with
these
these problems at the back end or should
we be doing more investment on the front
end or should we think about
also alternative mobilities for dealing
with the problems at the back end should
be dealing with mental health as opposed
to with
criminal justice i feel like in
healthcare we haven't
done nearly enough of that well to it's
a lot of times paid lip service and a
lot of the stuff that we pay lip service
to is stupid
like you know we need more wellness
programs in the workplace
like that's fine but it's not the big
thing the big thing
is there are huge pockets of american
society whose health is suffering
because
we've seen rampant racism or an opioid
epidemic that's due to the destruction
of
of jobs and and and opportunity in key
sect
and key parts of the country and we're
not going to deal with our health care
prices if we don't start to think much
more about
what is the pipeline that is producing
the problems that we are dealing with
down the road so okay
jacob let me let me pick up on that yeah
that was a lot
that third point and turn to phil and
just say
phil um and jacob jacob is was
was alluding to some of the root causes
in your description of uh
of the policing issues you you were also
talking about
social determinants and and i i wanted
to know if you have anything you'd like
to share on
on how the educational system um
contributes to this or could
uh do you have any ideas for for um
you know how the educational system
could be uh
used to help address some of these
problems you have any any views about
uh the quality of the educational system
that people um
uh experienced yeah i mean so uh one of
the ways that i've found to be newly
annoying
of late is to to ask the question back
to everyone
which one so when you say the education
system which one are we talking about
higher education
my hope is that i am currently warping
the minds of
uh 150 some odd undergraduates graduate
and professional school students
to get them to think about some of these
issues differently i imagine that you
were talking about the primary education
system don't worry i'm going to answer
that one
that was what i was surfing um in which
i said okay then which one
um because in several of the cities
where we work because
of the reaction against immigration they
have
um they have private schools that are so
dirt cheap in majority white
neighborhoods that they functionally
have reproduced
segregation which is why nicole hannah
jones it finds essentially
we've got schools that are just average
not more segregated than they were
before brown versus board of education
good job all deliberate speed
um so i think we have to think about
what we mean by education and what role
we want it to play
that said i've been shocked i mean you
know alan i've been working with
um increasingly complex models um for
how we
how we predict racial disparities and
where the variance
lives um in those ratios i'm shocked by
how much
primary education doesn't soak up
variance once you start looking at just
basically race
poverty and and sort of crime as
if it's not already baked in um but
there's good research that suggests
the longer kids are in school literally
during the day and the more time they're
in school over the course of the summer
the less likely they are
to get involved in petty crimes right so
you could
make an argument that if we made schools
better caretakers of particularly
adolescent children
that we could put a debt in the
in the crime rates i'd also though go
back to this and say
if the way that we deal with adolescent
um acting out
is punishing them with handcuffs and
cages
maybe the problem wasn't the kids in the
first place but that we imagined that
something about
normal adolescent development was
criminal so
there are absolutely ways that it seems
like increasing uh coverage and
resources
for um for schools can make a debt
particularly on adolescent crime rates
but that's only within a context where
we've taken for granted that it's okay
to criminalize
what absolutely isn't criminal in more
affluent neighborhoods or at least
it seems that way the trade-off between
the two like we have more control
over public education um in vulnerable
communities
so more resources and more counseling
there i mean we have
literally tens of thousands of
jurisdictions that have no counselors
but hundreds of law enforcement in the
schools so for sure more resources we
could make a dent
um and in favor of doing that of
creating the social services and
expanded hours
and capacity for primary education in
vulnerable communities
but the long-term solve of this i think
is solving the problem of
what is and isn't punishable or
punishment worthy
in the communities where we've given
them fewer options and that i think is
likely not going to be a job
that primary education can do hopefully
it's a job that folks who graduate
from secondary education will do as they
move into positions of power
great phil thank you so much so um we're
coming up to the end of our
time and i'd like to turn to the the
panelists
um and ask them for you know if they
have any uh final concluding thoughts
and i also um uh would would like if
they would like to of course
if you could recommend uh something you
read
that gives you special you know that you
think is especially
insightful in your policy area a blog
um or you know someone you follow that
you think is
is really on target um uh that you would
recommend to the
um recommend to the audience and then i
would also say
is there someone who's on the other side
of the issues that
from you just by someone god knows why
but it just always seems like this
person you know
you know kathy disagrees with me for
some reason like every time she has a
position it's always on the other side
but yet you learn something from from
that person so someone who's both
both someone who who you who resonates
with you and
as well as someone who might be on the
other side that you would recommend as a
place to turn
or for other perspectives that you find
valuable
so i'll go if we could go phil then then
jacob and then fiona
man um all right for
for the person i would read um there's a
young
um blogger and dative visualization
person who i think is phenomenal
his name is w.e.b du bois um i highly
recommend
she's got a number of books out i'm
being mildly facetious
um when i talk with um phil agnew who's
an activist
who came to popularity after the trayvon
martin shooting um
or what i'm talking with e-viewing who's
a poet and a scholar at uchicago
um i i come back they come back to
dubois as often as i do
so as much as i would love to talk about
the young people who i follow who are
fantastic
um like phil agnew like e-viewing um
i would say if you really want to be
involved in what the cutting edge is and
what's going to be
five years from now go back and read
dusk of dawn go back and read black
reconstruction by du bois because
all of the folks who i am teaching and
who i am learning from of the generation
be
uh younger than me that's what they're
doing
in terms of the people who are on the
other side of these things
alan i'm such a contrarian about this
stuff that i'm going to be difficult
also because i didn't have as much time
to think about who it would be um i
am i am of a mind that there shouldn't
be sides on this
and the rea and it's not a cop-out i'll
explain to you why um
the folks who are calling the sort of
most died in the wool
abolitionists um in the space of
policing
agree about 90 to 95 and their demands
with law enforcement executives the
place where they don't agree is how much
those law enforcement executives should
get paid
that's a serious disagreement but
the folks who are on the other side of
no policing should only get bigger
are not people that the executives take
seriously nor the activists take
seriously
so i'd say actually the one bit of good
news is that while there's lots of
tension right because the the theories
and diagnoses that we have
are are are being used to be put in
tension
the demands are actually quite a great
deal aligned
and because we also align on the fact
that we don't know where we're going
much less how we're going to get there
there is increasingly
unnecessary humility within this space
um
so i would say kat brooks is a person
you can talk to you can look you can
follow
who's tweeting right now and who's at
the the oakland anti uh police terrorism
uh network
is a great place to go for that kind of
stuff but i don't think it's because
there's disagreement i think it's
because there's synergy and spirited
debate on how we frame
and what we go after first terrific
thank you so much phil and thank you for
all of your comments during today's
uh panel jacob yeah so to keep it really
brief
i mean i don't think there's a single
source on health care
that there are a lot of different
resources that people can turn to
um you know what the
three places i find myself turning the
most when i just want to like sort of
figure out what's going on in the
present
are health affairs which is a well-known
journal
the kaiser health network and kaiser
family foundation sites
which are sort of like the one stop
source for a lot of this stuff
and then the data journalism done
on vox which is now probably moving to
with ezra klein over to new york times
so those are the three places i tend to
rely for just sort of what's happening
in the policy weeds
so i'm i'm going to be contraring a
little bit contrarian too which is to
say that like i i've had a lot of fights
uh with the right over the public option
and i don't find myself particularly
convinced um and so
and i feel like a lot like it's very
revealing that the people who remain
on the hard right on health care who are
the ones who helped
design say the the repeal and replace
legislation that
didn't happen in 2017 that they've
become increasingly removed
not just from the ideas i support but
from the ideas they once supported
like um the mandatory private health
insurance model
um so like stewart i'm a big fan of
stuart butler who used to be the
heritage foundation now he's at the
brookings institution so i can't say
that he's a conservative
but on that side on the left i mean they
come after me right
no pun intended right and left and on
the left
i really like jerry freeman um at amhert
umass amherst who's been writing a lot
about medicare for all lately don't
always agree with them but
um but he worked a lot with bernie
sanders and he has some interesting
recent writings he has a new book which
i had
near me lately which is making the case
for medicare for all
terrific thank you very much jacob and
again thank you for
all of your comments and participation
in tonight's panel and now um to wrap up
i guess
fiona uh you know scott morton i just
want to
second what jacob said i i will say that
the reason that repeal and replace never
got a replace
is because the affordable care act was a
comp was supposed to be
was a republican proposal it's
romneycare it's outsourcing
government-provided health insurance to
the private sector
so if you want if you're not going to
support that you're left with just
letting people die
which has been the default alternative
on the right so there really isn't
anybody to argue with it's kind of like
it's either an affordable care act or
move left from that so that that's a
problem for the intellectual debate
there
um so what do i follow that i think is
great uh there's a blog run by the
washington center for equal growth
called competitive edge which has really
nice antitrust analysis and
and competition topics uh slightly
broader covering more
regulatory topics as well as antitrust
is the
blog at the university of chicago booth
school of business called
pro market run by luigi singles and
that's a great
source of really uh fun topics and
and both easy to read and very
accessible
perfect i'm sorry yeah i have to answer
your second question
um in my field the other side to the
people who want
competition are uh are the people who
want corporate profits if you if you do
the
economic analysis right you maximize
social welfare with competition so
they're just there isn't an economist
who
doesn't think that's true um and so the
other side of this debate are the folks
who want corporate profits they're
um corporations obviously uh
the the people they pay to do
scholarship or that they encourage to do
scholarship
for reasons that are too long to explain
on this uh event
kind of stopped using economics tools
around 1980 or that is to say the tools
they use go up to 1980 but they don't
use economics
after 1980 more or less and so that
means there's a real shortage of
academics and scholars in my
field with whom you could debate because
the people who are in favor of profits
aren't really in
the journals so uh so i'm sorry that's a
kind of an
incomplete answer but there it is all
right there you go
thank you uh fiona again thank you for
that and thank you for your
participation
uh in tonight's panel um uh so this
concludes
our event uh again i'd like to thank the
panelists
and i'd also like to thank the
organizers
uh pam greene pamela monica torrey
bilsky and lemore peer
uh we're gonna have uh i guess the um
this is a recorded event so
we'll have the recording of this event
posted at the isps
website that's also the place you can go
to find out about
um upcoming isps events
uh thank you again for for sharing your
time with us this evening
and look forward to seeing you at future
isps
events thanks everyone
thanks all see you later everyone